all is quiet in an Talia's harbour
usually it's a lot busier this time of
year the captains of the tourist boats
here say visitor numbers have plummeted
up to seventy percent but they've got
their hopes up for summer the peak
season if the worst happens and tourists
don't come some have a plan B to her
operator grizzle guth hopes it won't
come to that you think I'd sell a ship
and go back to fishing that's just how
it works if the tours stay away I've got
to make money somehow giving up is out
of the question for feta Tommy che in
nearby belek he's turning a half a
billion euro investment into a theme
park complete with hotel roller coasters
and dolphin pools he expects to turn a
profit after a decade Tommy she already
owns 32 hotels a continue to invest this
is one of the biggest investment for me
and also for tourism in Turkey we do
something similar in Istanbul also as a
tourism destination because I am
creating destinations not just a hotel
his land of legends as the park is
called opens in two months the hotel is
already finished 20 to 30,000 visitors
are expected every day double that of
disneyland paris but the beaches for now
are deserted
the hotels are just as empty the
tourists who do come stay within the
hotel grounds but not all do so out of
fear well I mean it's a tourist place
and it's a bit off season so if I was a
terrorist I would not hit the place like
this yet fear is still a main concern of
the hotels 12 million tourists used to
come to Antalya each year bookings for
the upcoming summer season have dropped
dramatically while security costs have
risen at the same time you have much
more people on security but there as we
can say our guests cannot see them they
are like invisible so that nobody is
uncomfortable no one here can say for
sure how safe turkey is for tourists
that's why many Europeans are opting for
Spain when planning their summer
vacation